実は今日なんですけども
えええええ
ちょっと
うっ(-.-;)〜〜
ってなるかもしれないんですけども
僕はこの日のためにここ最近、頑張ってきたっていう
節はあるかもしれない
とも言えない
かもしれない
あの実はですね、
２０１８年の２月から遊戯王WCS
ワールドちゃぴお（チャンピオン）
か！！！
ワールド
ぶぉぉ！
ワールドチャンピオンシップ
世界大会の予選が日本で行われております。
いろんなね
遊戯王の公認のお店で大会が開かれます。
大会で優勝した人だけが
県とかの場所に
集められて
そこで1位になった人が国内予選
あの日本 一を決める大会
全国大会みたいなのに
出れるんですけど
その今、各お店の1 位を決める大会が 2 月から始まっております
で, それに今日僕出てきたわけなんですよ
てか、この日のために
結構 結構 頑張りました
で、去年ですよ
去年僕、一応お店で優勝して
静岡県の代表を決めるブロック戦に 出て
静岡県ベスト１６までは
いって、まぁ負けたんですけども
あの、正直、本当
めちゃくちゃ悔しくて
まぁ、勝ったか負けたか分かんないんですけど
なんか、店で負けたんですね、あの時
あ、動画あるんで是非見てください
店で負けちゃったんですごい悔しくて
悔しくて悔しくて悔しくて
今年は
今年もまぁ、同じレベルとまでとは言わないんですけど
行けるとこまで行きたいなと思ってまして
あの実はここ最近ですね、もう寝る間も惜しんで
朝まで何かこう、いろいろね考えたりして
デッキとか考えたりしてた日々が実はずっと続いておりました
この２月からの
国内予選のために
で、今日出てきたんですよ予選に
出てきた結果
１回戦
２回戦
３回戦
負けました
かぁぁぁ！
クソォ
負けたけど一応参加賞は貰えましたからね
出るだけで参加賞貰えますからね
負けちゃったんですけども
結局そのまま優勝したので
まぁ
チャンピオンに負けたならまぁ、
ok
みたいなところはあったんですけど、
まぁ、ちょっと悔しいなっていう思いがすごい
あります
いやぁ、とっても悔しいですね〜
まぁ、悔しいところではあるんですけども、
あ！
武力の軍奏だ！
はい！
めっちゃ、悔しかったんですけども、
あの実は、大会がですね
えっと、２月　３月　４月
3ヶ月間あって、そこでとりあえず一回でも優勝すれば
静岡県大会みたいな、県大会に出れるんですよ
なんですいません
あの〜非常にあれなんですけども
この場を借りて言わせてください
あの〜
頑張ります
はい
そんだけです。
でね、今日大会出て思ったことがあったんですけど
レベルが
上がってます
なんかもう、勝手にはじめ軍団ていう、なんかね
遊戯王する仲間を集めたんですけど
えっと今日出た大会で３２人なんですよ
で、そのうち、ベスト８の中に
一緒によく頑張ってる仲間が
５人入ってました
ベスト８中の５人が身内なんで
意外とね、なんか
ちゃんと練習すれば勝てるようになってきたな
っていう気はしてます
ほんと、よく頑張った。はじめ軍団のみんな
パチパチ
ていうか、今日あれだ
・・・
恵方巻きの日だ
でなんか、カードゲームって
ちょっと馬鹿にされがちなんですよ
うわっ
なに、遊戯王にそんなガチになってて
うわぁ
みたいなことなこと言われるんですけども
僕は、もう馬鹿にされてもいいと思ってます
世界大会ですよ
日本でわいちゃーやってるんじゃなくて
もう、世界目指してますからね
一応
はい、全然下手で終わるんですけども
今日１日ちょっと頑張って
お店の中で３回戦で負けちゃったんですけど
今年は、ちょっと
頑張りたいと思います
というわけで、動画が遅くなってごめんなさい
今、頭の中が
もう、何が何でもちょっと勝ちたいところがあるんで
今しばらく、
遊戯王に集中させてください
なんか、遊戯王だけやってますみたいな
そういう感じじゃないんですけど
遊戯王以外も忙しいんですけど
遊戯王の練習とかもちゃんとやんないと
マジで勝てないんで
いろんなことを込めて
たまに動画を
お休みすることが増えると思いますが
御了承ください
今…
俺が一番頑張りたいことを
頑張りたいとおもってるんで
遊戯王ですけどね
今日も大会だったんですけども
大会はですね、何回でも出れるんで
２月中もまだまだ大会があるので
もうちょっと頑張っていきます
次こそ
勝つz！！！
ありがとうございました(=^▽^)y